when I come into a house with buyers I
start picking it apart these are other
things wrong with it let's start making
a list Jim the Realtors from northern
San Diego and gained an online following
in 2009 when he started posting his
honest painful and sometimes hilarious
assessments of bank owned properties on
YouTube guess what causes the master the
exquisite furnishings these granite and
travertine palaces will be the
historical memory of this era lovely
it'd be better off just burning this one
down Clough insurance you spent some
time at a property with Jim to get his
grim forecast for the future of the
housing market and for some
straightforward talk about whether or
not to buy a house and if so how not to
be stupid about it market conditions are
healthy as long as we have low rates we
have what appears to be another couple
years of these ultralow fed induced
rates it's interesting what effect that
has if you're a buyer your kind of
thinking a I've got a couple of years I
don't have to rush it's probably the
thing that's the most surprising in this
area and I think it's going on in a lot
of other areas the supply of good houses
is that's just dropped off probably a
great snapshot for our market it's all
in spite of itself dated dated dated
everywhere you look but someone bought
it just because there's not enough other
houses to buy if you need to buy out
this is what you're stuck with both the
Bush and Obama administrations the big
emphasis was stopping foreclosures and
keeping people in their homes is that
something you agree with if they're
looking to do what's best for the market
they would unleash the floodgates and
let it rip because I'm convinced it
would cause a frenzy of buying to see
all these bank deals and people would
come running the amount of foreclosures
that could happen in the future is great
it could happen but they're not letting
them happen banks aren't just throwing
properties out there at half
is there not given these properties away
and when they do hit the market if it is
cheap it gets bit up that's the
definition of value are we going to sell
a bunch of dumps real cheap probably but
they're gonna sell real cheap whether
it's this year or next year anyway let's
just take our medicine all right so tell
us about this bathroom you have the 1991
version of this was hot in 91 what
policies do you think have been the most
harmful to the housing market refinance
of everybody who's underwater that's the
program at hot this year last year was
refinancing people who were heading for
foreclosure I don't think anything's
harmed the market they're just wasting
their time they're wasting their money
taxpayer money on these crazy programs
that are supposedly going to save the
day is my pool sinking no it's the
decking is going up the pool is not
going down the decking is probably
either got soaked underneath there and
water starting to make it rise or
there's some tree roots when will it
come back when are we going to see peak
pricing again I don't know not in the
foreseeable future and maybe never I
think we need to be prepared for being
never let's buy a house we have a place
to live period and not taking a friona
latex hate this whole investment they
well if it goes on and buy a house cuz
you like it you want to raise your
family and the good news is I think
today's buyer is exactly that and I
think that makes for a very healthy
market